I think there are two examples which
show I can think of many examples which
show how to die well one is Socrates who
is condemned to death unjustly by the
Athenian democracy and he isn't forced
to swallow the hemlock but there's no
rage in Socrates he no he could have
escaped he chooses not to escape he
swallows the hemlock he is thinking all
the time of other people he washes his
body to save the women the trouble he
jokes kindly with his jailer he doesn't
reel against him and he sits and accepts
the loving companionship with his
friends as he drinks the head they have
love there's no rage there's a big
accepting kindness and that was not just
because Socrates got a blast from God at
the end but because his whole life had
been about facing the unknown preparing
for this moment sitting loose to life
and ego and lifts emptying himself
compassionately in dialog with other
people in a Socratic dialogue the kind
of conversations he had with other
people nobody won the argument everybody
realized that they knew nothing at all
and that they listened and it always had
to be conducted throughout with
gentleness there must be no anger or
malice and that endless discipline
throughout his life enabled him to face
this unjust death and the other one is
Jesus who on the cross in the depths of
agony is presented by the Gospel writers
as having time to have a kindly word for
one of his fellow victims to make
provision for his mother and forgive his
executioner's but again we don't know
much about Jesus's disciplines but he
had lived a compassionate life it won't
just come at the end
I've just seen my mother through her
last years and a lot of of the distress
that she'd experiencing and I've came to
the fore in the end things that she
hadn't really dealt with we had now is
the time to prepare for death the lot of
the religions say that life is a
preparation for death which sounds
morbid but extinction something we find
very very difficult to cope with the
idea that we're not going to be here
anymore and that we've got to go through
as the Buddha always said sickness old
age and an undignified death he himself
suffered death of dysentery in some
jungles miles from his friend and that I
saying comforting his comforting his
followers say don't worry about me you
have got in yourself the means to go on
thinking of them and I'll tell you one
personal story if you like of somebody
who was dying and who made an immense
impact on me and has made has remained
an icon with me when I was a young nun
we were trained quite abrasively
people who read my story always think it
reminds them of boot camp in the army
and you don't expect your sergeant major
to be full of compassion towards you
he's supposed to be training you to face
fire and to be tough but I had one
superior who was kind and she had a room
life at the age of 29 she'd gone deaf
and has had a very good mind but she'd
spent all the intervening years I think
sounds like 43 or 30 or 40 years
sewing mending sheets in in in the
laundry you'd think a waste of a life
and anybody has got to become rageful
and bitter but she didn't and at the end
of her life she was dying all the year
when she was training me she was dying
of cancer when I arrived in her
community
she's been given three weeks to live but
she lasted the whole year and she
refused to take any painkillers because
she said they would make her head Muzzy
and she was dealing with young people
and had to be alert for them now you
couldn't put her on a pedestal because
she was really quite eccentric in many
ways had many kind of quirky
eccentricities she was used to get
furious if we broke things and as a
result we were also nervous I've never
broken so many things in the whole
course of my life but I was beginning to
realize that I was going to have to go
and my body was telling me already I was
starting with vomiting sickness
nosebleeds all psychosomatic symptoms
that I was going to have to leave the
convent but she was always so kind then
came the day when they were going to
take her away to the mother house to die
and she was in there very full of pain
skin and bones we all went in the young
downs to say goodbye to her and she
smiled rather like Socrates and joked
with us and said she'd been looking down
from us on heaven and you know she'd be
dead soon and all the rest of it sent us
out and she asked me to come back and I
went and knelt by the bed and she said
sister I always I was told that you
would be a troublesome young woman I
want to tell you you have never been a
trouble to me you've been a good girl
sister and we always remember I told you
so you are a good girl and then she put
a handle on my head and blessed me and I
went out now for someone in an extreme
of agony to take notice to no doubt a
rather annoying
young woman troubled young woman in that
moment of extremity I've never forgotten
that
but that's she had trained herself
through all those difficult years
not to become bitter not to think why me
why my deafness why am I wasting my life
and as a result she's remained in me as
an icon of what a good person should be